there's the question she visits Avram
c.com to ask what are the steps to
catching up on saving for retirement at
50 years of age
I feel the window to save as closing but
also trying to remain hopeful and focus
help well here's the reality you know
Angie you've got to be aware of your
dream and know what it is you're chasing
and why it matters to you and it is
never too late if you wake up with air
in your lungs you've got an opportunity
but you have to have a plan you've got
to get on a budget you got to get
allergic to debt and now right now sell
some stuff look at taking on a second
job if you have to but you have to
delete the unnecessary in your life so
you can grab what's valuable and you may
have to look at downgrading lifestyle
and you do those things that I'm going
to tell you're gonna grab back control
get over to Ramsey plus get plugged into
a community so you're not doing it alone
but you feel connected and that's how
you do it Dave
yeah that's exactly right the window is
closing
yeah mathematically and yet the shortest
distance between where you are and
wealth is still the baby steps it's
still get your emergency fund in place
and get rid of your debts which gives
you the cash flow to pour into your
retirement and and you know increasing
that and getting it up to 15% if you
save fifteen percent of your income from
age 50 to age 65 and you have an average
income you'll be able to retire mm-hmm
and I suspect you might make more than
that and you might work longer than that
through that period of time it wouldn't
be unusual for someone in their 50s
average income entails also taking into
account what people that are 22 years
old make right and so typically a 50
year old has an opera has had an
opportunity to grow their career and I
don't know what you do Angie but I'm
just gonna make a reasonable statistical
assumption that you have an
above-average income
well it's time it's possible I mean
that's the thing that I want people to
hear out there Dave because I still get
this question a lot is it too late can I
still do it well I know you can the
bigger question is will you yeah I mean
you got to treat it like the house is
burning down yeah you I mean this it's
urgent
yeah you will
do and I think you panic and skips no no
no no not at all no I just you just have
an extra urgency to work the steps
because the quicker you get out of debt
the quicker you have your income in your
control to build wealth with mm-hmm and
so just turn up the heat on that baby
right and be allergic to excuses now
Dave I had a coach he was about 150
years old that's that's not true cuz
that make him biblical but he was old
and crotchety he probably wasn't
biblical at all
but he told us something that as as
players out there he said don't make
excuses make plays and I say that in
this because even in the period of kovat
19 right now
people can use that as an excuse not to
stay focused on the plan and it's really
important not to do that for yourself
because that's how you end up losing a
year or two or three because we're gonna
say I'm gonna wait until this or I'm
gonna wait until that no no no be urgent
right where you are right now and don't
make excuses for stupid yeah that dogged
intensity dogged determination that
pushes through in spite of the obstacles
is the one that crosses the finish line
go and bust the tape and that's you you
can do this answer